assalamualaikum warahmatullah better
care to brothers and sisters and dear
friends welcome to this video before I
start I want to praise Allah subhana WA
Ta'ala the most merciful the most
gracious or praises glory and gratitude
on Tardos panel taro for all the works
that we bring and now this video of mine
is not a video that I usually do or it's
an area which I would like to go
personally but unfortunately within my
character that I know of myself I can't
tolerate injustice no matter who is done
to a Muslim a non-muslim when I see
injustice done I personally cannot
tolerate it and if I find and I find way
up the good and bad of the actions or
the words that I'm about to say then
obviously if I believe that it's going
to bring more good than bad I will try
my best to stop that injustice with the
best of my ability with this video
I fought about it a lot vanished the
higher are three times and I did we
believed in my heart I believe in
injustice was done to check anything
I've had that that's why I believe that
with the following that I have and I
don't mean to sound in an arrogant way
but I have to use that following to the
best of my advantage and I believe
without following for me to clarify
Sheratons position even though the ship
himself is not aware of this video and
he himself and would personally that I
know him would tell me and II don't do
the video but I personally believe
within myself that I have to do this
video because I don't believe I can put
my head to my pillow comfortably at
night knowing that this injustice has
been done towards a chef so that's why I
came to the conclusion of doing this
video now brothers and sisters I want to
before I go through every point one by
one I want to tell you guys a bit of a
background of I shall hate him and her
dad so you guys know him and what kind
of a character and what kind of a ham
what kind of a humble person is and what
kind of a lovely man he is and who has
greatly benefited
oh ma this shet Haytham is being labeled
as not being a scholar one lion's share
hate him by his humility and his
humbleness he doesn't even care for you
to call him a scholar or not it doesn't
matter he doesn't that's the least of
his worries for it for you to call him a
scholar or not the issue is
disrespecting somebody of high knowledge
somebody who's old enough to be your
father
you may not believe he's a scholar but
to disrespect him fear Allah son of
Italian what you are doing this is
unfair this is injustice so I just want
to move on since we have clarified up
100 Allah any good that comes from this
video is from Allah and inshallah it is
for Allah subhana WA Ta'ala anything bad
that comes from this video is for myself
on my ignorance and from the Shaitaan
now let's get straight into who is our
beloved Sher Shah hey thermal Haddad
what's his worse who did he study with
what has he produced for the community
and for the Ummah this is very important
the first thing that I need to do by
defending the shed is by talking about
who he is and what he's been doing for
the community in sha allah so we're
going to go for that
Shelia term and Haddad was born in Saudi
Arabia and he had the privilege handle
is not to study under many scholars and
some of those scholars of sham dinesh
mentioned by name is for example he
studied under shacking bars for him
Allah the the matter of faith and he was
known as a Grand Mufti of Saudi Arabia
at the time he also studied with Chef
green which is the same share for him
rahim allah and this is the same share
abdullah even tripling in a garden of
terrible in pointed out to shed hate
them and said this man is animal
Motley's
a sincere scholar this is what the chef
said not only that share his and her dad
may Allah bless him also studied on the
shed a bit are killed for 15 years and
in the biography of Shah even a kill he
mentions the shed
was one of his senior students not only
that chef even a kill game the authority
to shake hate them to compile the
letters that Shelly battalion had with
his teacher
Abdul Rahman as sovaldi and she hated
them later on bought these letters and
compounded in a book and he was praised
for this word by she even a keel and
chef of a man rahim allah so we are
talking about a person who is sincere in
his knowledge and a scholar now brothers
and sisters look at the list of the
scholars names that I gave and the
praises that was given the chef he
themand had that and the work that he's
been done he's been doing what la he
isn't it injustice in the highest degree
that you dare to look at this man and
feed him he has no knowledge well I feel
most fun wa taala in the words that come
out of your mouth they sing in my
language in my other traditions a word
comes out the mouth ones you can't take
it back
well ma he by our fear there's things
that you are uttering anyways Roxanne
sisters let's move on a bit forward she
hate him and her dad also studied
shalyah in Sudan and has done many works
for the youth and the community and he
has many students who have become Imams
leading figures in their community dies
out there and these individuals come to
him for advice on a regular basis Chad
hey Sam and her dad is known to be a
person who wants to bring unity in the
community he is known to do works
traveling abroad going for talks and
lectures spending time with students she
hates him cause that o heat now the way
you cause to wit maybe differ to certain
other brothers who call Tutor weed but
he calls it so he by making his students
and the people realize that others want
allah is the ultimate greatest one that
should be worshipped and they should
believe that in their heart since i've
got this out of my chest handle in LA I
feel like a fan justice to shake a therm
and her dad even though I said before he
would not even allow me to do this video
but this is something personal to me
that I had to do
is that brothers and sisters the matter
of student loans being Haram ojala now
before you guys get excited I think whoa
brother added I was going to give us a
fat one now make up like I said before
guys it is not my place
it is not my place to even talk about
this matter now I just want to clarify a
few points to you guys of what I heard
this is not a fatwa this is not me see
this Haram Mahalo my position is I don't
know I don't know and when I first heard
it I looked into the matter
I was curious I wanted to know and I
asked people of knowledge from Medina
University and they told me the
following in the matter and the reason
why I mentioned in this to you is for
you guys to understand that says hey
Thurman Haddad is being portrayed that
he said philippa is halal basically the
student loans Libra is helada and this
is injustice and this is a slander
against against your Clayton and her dad
because sure hey the mother she hated
her dad is the very same person who
passed on a fatwa to the Islamic banks
about their mortgage not being halal I
mean they're being challah and he looked
into handling death and said this is her
on the very ship are you accusing that
he's saying riba is halal apparently
which is a slander which is the slander
is the same person imposed on a fatwa to
the Islamic bands that what you're doing
is a RIBA so brothers and sisters before
we do a judgment and hear some stories
and believe in it
fear Allah so Allah clarify it and
inshallah this guy this will make you
realize that she hate them and her dad
will never say the Ripper is Helen and
the reason why he would not do this is
because she hate him and her dad
believes that in its core essence
student loan is not the RIBA do you
understand what I'm trying to say the
chef believes I'll repeat once again I
am NOT think the halal or Haram I'm
neutral
this you bidding is all wrong may Allah
bless you after all right I'm doing that
you've been in this Anna you have the
opinion that's called the back-up good
on you
but what China sees shed his man had
that it is essence says this is not a
river transaction now let's say before
share hey Theo and had that to a site
may Allah bless him this is the
following things that I have heard from
a couple of people from major scholars
in Saudi Arabia and I'm going to mention
the names so you guys can have that
judgment to yourself because this was
brought up to these colors and asked if
this is the case right and once again I
repeat we are not seeing is liberal and
that is the silly thing to ask you know
that's a really silly thing talk that's
not me going to see his inner Holland of
course whoever you ask this shift like
if you go to hate them and ask him for
example a question that was asked to
another chef if she comes in this river
click who is libel but what we're trying
to say is that the shitless of living
this essence now I'm going to further
name you the following which I heard
from a student of a media University
which I do not want to mention by name
is the following
he said he went and asked sheikh
muhammad baba bucker
who is the head of islamic finances in
medina university and he asked him this
question and he was told that this is
not river this is the river head of
islamic economics in the medina
university this is not someone it's not
your Tom Dick and Harry this is not a
normal person this is what he said now
once again I repeat I am NOT saying this
haha I'm not saying this Haram I'm just
trying to make you guys understand the
matter is not clear-cut for me it's not
even who else was asked chef moo-stache
ankiets was also asked and he is one of
the biggest colors in medina and his
biggest students chef is bigger student
shell I met her she was asked who is a
specialist and finances said this is not
River
who else was asked this were the women
also asked asked shed Abdul Aziz who
Jamie and he said the following that
it's not Reba or the river is no clear
cut not only that also sure Haytham and
her dance teacher chef even Jibreel and
one of his biggest students which is
muhammad nasir Shahi bonny was asked
about this very matter and he said the
river here is not clear-cut now once
again I repeat this is what has been
conveyed to me when I was looking at the
matter 'non convenient to you I am NOT
saying it's halal I am not seeing in
this Haram I don't know what I want to
say to you guys is the matter is not
clear-cut
even if you push I hate them mail them
listen to a site and go to these colors
this is what they have said now you know
what the funny thing is guys it also
depends on how the question is asked
because a funny story has happened which
was conveyed to me that a brother who
believes that student loan is Libba went
to a scholar which the the boxing cannot
remember when did his corner and asked
him about this and the schoolís
immediately said this is RIBA straight
up and a brother you just want to be
named went to the same share and asked
him about the student loan and you know
the Sheikh said he said anybody that
says this is RIBA is jar in his jacket
is ignorant like if he says if he says
no I equip myself if he says this is
clear-cut riba is JA he'll one T one
person goes and expressed in a way it's
River another goal person wasn't
explains it
it's a he's being called a jacket no
prophet insists that you understand what
we're trying to see here this is the
matter at hand so that's why it is sad
for a lay man or any of us to govern in
my race and others around RIBA know that
people gonna see is rebirth is Hara with
no rebeis haram so brothers and sisters
before I finish I just want to say
something I just want to say shame on
those
shame on those who look for the fault of
another believer and trying to stay this
image fear loss upon what I like new
dealings fear Allah in your dealings
or lying if you try to look for the
fault of other people other believers
Alice one time we'll find your very own
fault like at the beginning of the video
a call a narration that we put by a
prophet muhammed sallalahu is seldom
salallahu alayhi wasalam so brothers and
sisters let's be careful in what we do
let's be careful how we act and let's be
careful at the words that come out of
our mouth now when asking things to
scholars we need to ask it the right way
if we have an agenda in our hardware
that you know what let's ask in this
manner so he can give us this ruling and
then we can like seriously can you
imagine if there is 0.00001% of apple in
my orange juice something that a lot of
these are on curtain you cannot change
it if I say you know what no I can't
drink it for example and somebody goes
no you can't you drink an alcohol yet
and he says you know I'm gonna go and
ask my the teacher he goes to his
teacher and he says a key that's not
sorry sorry go see teacher says yeah
share and is alcohol al-khaliq drink
permissible the ship's gonna say is her
own but did you explain in detail did
you say it's an orange juice that has
0.001 percent of alcohol in it
no you're going and convey the message
to Asia who doesn't know what's going on
and explain intimacy is alcoholic drinks
permissible she's gonna look at you and
say of course it's not permissible unto
man if you go say ah but there's this
scholar who says it's permissible he's
gonna say that's cool what canvas
crazies was his mind vas injustice and
every student of knowledge knows that
when you ask a question to a chef based
on the information you give is how the
answer and the muling comes to you the
[ __ ] was given to you that's my brothers
and sisters I ask everyone to inshallah
share this video before you do also
check the link if you want to know more
about your religion without being
narrow-minded having respect to
different people's opinions please do
check out severe retreats where you are
being taught this in detail know about
your religion genre and like I said
Bob's and sisters may always want to
have mercy on every single one of you
guys forgive me if I've hurt anyone and
my aim with this video is not
anyone initially perform but I felt the
duty upon me to defend the chef and
hamdulillah I'm happy with what I've
done and may I accept it for me and I
don't want to go back and forth of
anyone inshallah my next video will be
Ross eating challenge I'll be eating
some grass for a charity inshallah
please do check that out
male has wanted a blessing missing one
of you guys please share this video for
see--koala
if you want to defend on up CheY hate
them I ask you for like your brother in
the religion share this video with
everyone with everyone you can I said
I'm gonna come when I mentally better
care to and I want to thank everyone who
helped me to bring this video together
and bring it to you guys
shoo-shoo shoo-shoo